but yeah no so uh a few weeks ago i
watched the
jojo event of course you did of course i
did where part six was announced
which is why everyone watched it because
they were like will part6 get announced
who knows man imagine if they didn't
announce part six after all that
i think it would have been very sad i
should probably explain uh if you're not
a jojo fan don't worry don't explain
basically there's a whole event around
jojo
uh they didn't say they were gonna
announce the new anime adaptation uh but
everyone was like
they said it's the biggest event in jojo
history so
i think they're going to announce it
otherwise i don't think this is the
biggest event do they normally do jojo
events
just randomly out of the blue i've never
heard of one well this is this has been
planned
for a very long time apparently actually
right a year ago i think actually have
they done one before this
i feel like they have but then but then
if you go to youtube and you type in
jojo live on tv yeah they constantly get
the voice actors to do
kind of what they did in this event yeah
yeah um so i guess i'll walk you guys
through the event basically what
happened yeah because i didn't get to
watch it i didn't get to watch it either
i just saw the reaction um yeah the
reactions we'll get into that
okay uh first of all the event we
weren't really told anything so
you didn't know anything that was
happening all we knew is that there was
a 40
price tag to watch the livestream
pay-per-view
pay-per-view yeah 40 bucks jesus wow
which is uh
little c you know eating your heart out
jake paul and we were
yeah right you shoot boxing now jojo
read please
um but it was yeah it was a pay-per-view
and we weren't told anything before all
right we're just told it's going to be
the biggest event
in jojo history at a reverb
as if they don't say that for every
event you know how they are in japan i
feel like they hyped things up way
beyond belief
yeah yeah and yeah again we weren't told
anything so essentially what happened
was that they did like kind of like a
game show kind of thing in the start
with some of the voice actors so
every uh main character joseph uh if you
don't know jojo don't really worry about
it it's not important basically the
voice actors they were like they quiz
them about the show
it's kind of like meh game show it's
basic japanese tv
yeah yeah it was basically like family
feud but with the jojo character which
actually sounds really good actually
i could make that i want to watch that
what did you do in the quiz well i
i did we'll get into this actually okay
and then you know it was like cool and
the voice actors performed some of their
scenes which was like the best part
yeah yeah you know they would do uh uh
they would all do the most dramatic
scene from their respective
part in the show which is really good um
yeah and then in the end they announced
it and uh it went over the time so it's
especially two hour event
and my god did they talk a lot they very
much it wasn't like a
like fast it was like let's just talk
about the show about the scenes
how did the scenes make you feel tell us
about it and yeah it was fine it's fine
um
but there was a few things that were
noteworthy about the event uh first of
all uh is that the subtitles
were unusable unreadable awful
ah so this i said this was a live event
yeah
but a live event that was pre-broadcast
like pre-recorded yeah it was all all
yeah that broadcast sorry pre-recorded
totally yeah um
it was i'm not sure if it was
intentionally gonna be so it's a live
playback in other words
it's a live re replaying it they
basically just made a youtube premiere
right yeah well right i mean that's
basically it right it was edited like a
live japanese tv show
where like it was very minimal i guess
minimal in terms of japanese editing and
stuff on screen
right next time we do a trash taste
special that we got to make that
pay-per-view now man
we do we should do what are we doing
we're [ __ ] dumb
doing it for free
and it's self-funded oh my god
so yeah it was it was it was forty
dollars yeah
which you know for a live event yeah a
bit hefty and you could buy a whole
season of jojo on dvd for that or
something right
you could buy four episodes of a jojo on
blu-ray for that you know
and don't get me wrong the event was
very good it was very well made but it
was just tragic because you know
how many events shot forty dollars for
you to watch them
not a lot i mean maybe like a concert of
like a mid-ranged artist is like 40
dollars all right but
online though yeah not online i feel
like boxing events
yeah i feel like boxing ones are the
only ones that may be wrestling
uh or they're right sure i'm not like uh
i don't watch wrestling
um but those are the ones i think of
yeah but usually
pay-per-view yeah usually it's like you
know if you're paying 40 bucks you have
it's a
in person experience right most of the
time i would like to think but with
boxing as well they do it online as well
and it's always like a [ __ ] 80 bucks
oh yeah yeah i mean i feel like with
boxing it's different to a lot of
sporting of
other sporting events because people
like you're building up months and
months
this one moment whereas other things
like football or you know basketball
there's like constant matches throughout
the season right but with boxing you
have one event that people build up
months to
and that's it so i can i can understand
the pay-per-view price or that model
kind of
in that kind of sense boxing fans are
hardcore this is where i think like do i
not understand the japanese market
enough because i'm like is this like the
same level as a
like a international boxing event in
japan like this jojo event is it like
the same level of like
everyone is everyone's stopping what
they're doing right well you know jojo
fans are
yeah but i wonder i i wonder if this is
like is this
the price is this high because they're
banking on jojo fans being as dedicated
as
they are yeah which they are which they
are yeah um or is it that they think
it's that big of an event in general in
japan i mean
i feel like i feel like it's a japanese
business model period
because i feel like it's the only
country that can sell blu-rays for like
hundreds of dollars
for like four episodes sometimes yeah
for a special edition and
people here will still buy it yeah and
uh
watching this live event was fun because
the live tweets were
quite quite interesting people were not
very happy all right um on the english
it was really yeah it was really yeah i
mean it was really interesting seeing
how all the negativity got wiped away
the moment that like part six was
announced and everyone's like guys
guys it's worth it it was the event was
worth it two hours of [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah because so essentially
right uh the
again it was it was pre-recorded so this
could have been subtitled pro like
properly it's not you know you can get
budget subtitles
and translations done you know for this
kind of length
like you know we get subtitles done for
the podcast i think yeah
to get the the podcast captioned it's
like 150
an episode uh but if you wanted to
translate it i think it would be
into japanese for like an episode like
this which i think is around the same
length
is like maybe like 800 bucks yeah so
it's not in terms of a big business
800 bucks for that kind of thing for
like low end translating
yeah not that much right yeah but
instead they decided for some reason
to do auto-generated subtitles and
that's never a good sign
there was like there was like people
were just posting screenshots of the
subtitles where it's like i'm gonna kill
a kid or something with one of them
or something like really funny out of
context like it was just
really bad yeah to the point where it
was like this is
unwatchable if you don't know any
japanese like the subtitles are so bad
and it was just like i just wondered why
like this is such a good event like you
have a
if you're a jojo fan this event was
amazing yeah yeah it's the kind of stuff
that
if it was on youtube it had like five
million views guaranteed yeah i'm
wondering like do you think they even
thought about the international audience
or were they just
really marketing towards the japanese
audience i don't think
like even me living in japan i only
heard about it like the day before and
that's because
you [ __ ] posted about it like i did
not know
like this wasn't talked about at all on
my timeline at least
i didn't know about it until just as it
was happening yeah if
if this was an event right where they it
was only really able
you're only able to pay in yen you were
only able to buy from a japanese website
yeah i would
i would be like that's a fair argument
you know you went on the job yeah
yeah you went out of your way to pay in
the currency you're expected to listen
to it in japanese
you you knew what you were getting into
some super fans if they don't understand
the word that's fine
but for me it was like all right so
they're premiering the show in like
uh singapore us specifically they have
website in english
where they're charging you in dollar and
they're telling you that it's going to
be subtitled
i think it's kind of [ __ ] up like yeah
the event was great
and it's just so sad that they kind of i
feel like they mislead the people a bit
oh yeah absolutely
i mean when have automated subtitles
ever worked they barely work for
for captioning the language that they're
doing
they barely work for our own language
when we upload it on youtube right
there's auto subtitles
what were they thinking yeah it's been
known to be one of the hardest languages
to translate into english yeah
i think slightly different grammatically
i think in terms of uh cost per like
uh like per minute of translating
japanese to english is one of the most
expensive
i'm not surprised by that because it's
the hardest and there's not there's not
many people that can do it it's
grammatically completely different
right so then who decided that they
should be like this is a great idea
and we're gonna charge forty dollars for
this i mean i i would think for a forty
dollar price you would get like more
professional subtitles
like because i guess this is the first
i'm hearing about this but like when i
hear live events i think you know
you you you understand there's some
leeway in an actual live event where
it's
happening right as it's airing right but
if it was
pre-recorded then yeah i mean you could
have you could it was
there was nothing about this show that
needed to be live yeah there was there
was no aspect of it that required a live
well
yeah if it's pre-recorded then like it's
not like it's not like the host can
interact with the chat or
anything like that right so you're
telling me you paid forty dollars just
to see a part 6 announcement
yeah and i do it again
jojo fans are offensive
pay for something i would have got like
five minutes later anyway
you know i don't know i you know i i sat
down i was like this isn't
40 dollars yeah yeah just the subtitles
the subtitles just it's like
you know at what point is it like do i
need a refund you know what i mean
how bad do the subtitles have to be
where it's like i can't understand
anything that's being said well i mean
i think that's worthy of a refund right
like you you paid for something that you
didn't even really understand yeah yeah
and they didn't even like give you the
chance to try and understand
it's really unfortunate as well because
people were like dogging on them on
twitter and then the
jojo anime account yeah tweeted out
being like hey guys
uh because there was a lot of people
streaming it on twitch right and they
were like guys please don't pirate it
there and then
there was one this is like i feel like
as a company you should never ever say
this you should never ever say the words
there is no excuse to pirates
right because i guarantee within 10
seconds
there is going to be 10 people with 10
semi-decent reasons why they pirated so
for example
and this is terrible so this show was
only available
in the u.s uh singapore and i think a
few other asian countries yeah yeah
no europe no europe at all right no
none of the other american countries
nothing not even not even canada
not even canada yeah so they were like
this in this tweet they said there is
no excuse to pirate this thing yeah and
then in brackets they said
sorry for the territory limitations and
i'm thinking like
oh no so what is it what is a european
fan supposed to do
yeah every year fingers unanimously
feels like a european
what am i supposed to do tell me what i
chose to do i'll just just be born
better
yeah just just just be born in a better
country
obviously obviously come on obviously i
i'm not i'm not promoting piracy yeah
but there is a way as a company where
that you can word things or go about it
just fly to asia so you can watch it
from asia during appendages
just live in japan just just leave it do
you like anime just live in japan
it's just it's so frustrating because it
feels like
i mean it feels like this argument yeah
i mean this i feel like companies should
already have a
understanding that like territory
limitations are like i
in my opinion the the biggest reason why
people pirates absolutely
it's it's been like this since [ __ ]
the internet was invented
basically like lost media i firmly
believe
you know you should be able to if it's
abandoned where or or
completely lost and there's no you know
i honestly i think that's okay to pirate
i i don't
like why would that not be okay like no
one has a stake in this anymore yeah
like
like isn't like playstation or sony
shutting down the ps3
psp ps vita stores now yeah so like you
know
even though even though like you know i
cuz i own i own a ps vita
and when i heard that i was like [ __ ]
what if there's a game that i want on
the ps vita i don't know what it is now
yeah but like i'm not gonna be able to
obtain it it's it's just lost media now
right yeah and if you're not gonna make
it readily available then someone's
going to archive this
you know and i it's it's
it's it's a it's a gray area but i feel
like there is
you know there is a reason why people do
want to pirate do you want to like
archive this stuff yeah there's
definitely like it's not a matter of
like oh there's
there's no excuse to pirate when it's
like no there really is an excuse to
pirate because it's literally
the only way i'll ever be able to get a
hand on it right i mean it's like if
you you would get someone who gets into
your product who never would have been
able to and never would have had a
chance to yeah right
and again with this live stream it's
like why is this livestream only in
some countries like is it because
they're perhaps showing scenes from the
anime
is it probably a lie probably is
actually it's probably a licensing thing
but still it's like
but it's a live stream you know i mean
it's not like you can't get it in every
country
i mean i mean i feel like that kind of
mentality just hasn't
adapted to just how the internet works
and just
how the camera works now in 2021 or even
[ __ ] 2010
yeah because all the laws are just
complete
all like the laws are like completely
outdated because they're all
laws that are made for like television
broadcasts and stuff like that right
especially in japan
yeah especially in japan it just wasn't
i mean we don't even have fair use laws
here
yeah which is ridiculous well i mean
it's it's i feel like at least in the us
there is a mentality of okay well
technically you know live streaming a
game and not paying
the the you know for a license to do
that yeah just technically
you know legally speaking you're not
allowed to do that yeah but all the us
companies just kind of agreed it's
beneficial
let them do it yeah but i feel like pam
that thing doesn't really happen no
there's not a there's there's not really
a thing of it's beneficial so let them
do it you know it's just another you
know
it's like when you get events like this
you're just reminded that you know
you're another one of those anime fans
uh being
westerner that yeah they don't care
about you
i mean i mean i i feel like the
mentality is slowly i mean it took
this long for it to change with like
western companies so god you know
it's going to change with japanese it is
changing out of [ __ ] snails
i mean like i would say at least
japanese companies know that we exist
now
that's that's that's that's the biggest
difference right because imagine like
five years ago where
they had a american or they had like an
english site to promote a japanese
lifestyle you know we are taking
very small steps we've gone from snail
mail to dial up email